Wahoo!
Congratulations!
You are just about
done with this course.
In a few moments, you are going to be
introduced to the requirements for
the final project of the course.
But, before I get to that,
I want to talk about quizzes.
You've probably noticed that
we like to put a lot of
quizzes in our courses because
that's just how people learn.
You're taking this course because
you want to make your apps faster.
So it makes sense for us to give
you a lot of sites to analyze and
dejankify as you go through the course.
But of course, not every quiz
involves you debugging apps.
We also like to pepper in quizzes,
like these, that we hope will give you
a better conceptual understanding of
what you're trying to accomplish.
I want to talk about myself for
a second.
When i started working on
this course with Paul,
I thought i knew a bit about getting
60 frame per second performance.
But as we worked together and
thought through all the questions that
we wanted to ask you, I realized that I
really didn't understand frontend
performance as well as I thought.
As any teacher will attest,
you don't really understand a subject
until you try to explain
it to somebody else.
In fact, the act of teaching and
deciding what questions to ask is
actually a much better learning exercise
than simply answering questions.
To that end I have a challenge for
you, can you teach this
course better than us?
Think back to the questions
that we asked you and
the examples that we
gave you to work on.
Do you have an idea for a better
question that could have been asked?
Or do you have a better app that
people should be debugging?
Or even better do you think
you can stump Paul and
me with some kind of
performance question?
If so, head back to that
particular part of the course and
post your question in the forums.
And when you do that,
start your post with better question.
There are two big benefits for
asking questions.
You'll be boosting your understanding
of performance by thinking through it
a little bit more deeply and you'll make
the course better for everybody else.
Future students will practice what
they're learning with more questions and
walk away with a better
understanding of performance.
It's really a win win, so
do you have a better question
than what we've come up with?
If so, post in the forums because I
cannot wait to start answering them.